then what's your advice to these small
business founders today we're card
you're gonna need some luck but the
harder you work the luckier you get and
if it doesn't work out that's not the
end of the world I just don't have
anything in common with people that sit
there and say oh my god it was terrible
so it's over it's water over the dam
under the bridge get on with it and
start another business the next day or
another career and be honest look in a
mirror and say why didn't it work out
well it wasn't the skill set or it
wasn't I didn't have the temperament for
it or I was in the wrong place wrong
time maybe I can't afford to do it again
maybe I can't but people aren't honest
with themselves they what I've always
done is I've taken a yellow pad I draw a
line down the middle write out the pros
on one side the cons on another in a
sense that if I let you see it you
wouldn't laugh at me and then when I get
done I just rip it up and throw it away
because I've worked out in my mind what
is real and what isn't and what I can
present to people and what I can't then
Lloyd when you look at mistakes is there
something is there a piece of advice you
wish you got as you were climbing up the
right look yes I wish I had gotten the
advice not to be intimidated to
understand to break all the myths that
are out there that you have to know once
intimidated yes
and by the way it's not a it's not a
listen it's not a vice it's not a bad
thing to be intimidated if instead of
paralyzing you it forces you to prepare
to over prepare to rehearse to try to
get it right to go back and review one
more time
I don't think that that's a I don't
think it's a bad thing but if it
paralyzes you if it intimidates you from
going on then it's a bad thing I think
one of the one of the things that I've
learned and I think that the mayor sees
clearly is how terrific these people all
are they are fantastic you would think
that the people that we talk today the
couple of dozen people that we spoke
today were from central casting the
3,500 people that we've already brought
through this program could all be like
that given all substitute and very often
the best thing that we can do for them
is break the myth bubble that they can't
do something that it's hard to do
something and what this program has done
for people
is it's given them kind of a little mini
MBA they get to hear stories of other
entrepreneurs but they learn a little
bit about accounting how to negotiate
how to make a business plan they hear
experiences for others and slowly but
surely it takes away the mythology and
they say oh my goodness I can't do what
that person has done to instead saying I
can do what that person has done you
didn't say how to sell how how important
is it to have salesmanship you could
have the better I don't know any
business where sales isn't a big part of
it or cooperation and collaboration
isn't a big part of it I suppose if
you're a monk and have vows silence
maybe but an author for example you've
got to work with an editor you've got to
talk to your publisher and you have to
deal with your family and it's there all
this is a world and I think it's good
where you don't do anything by yourself
nobody just works for one person or just
works for themselves nobody does
anything independently we deal and and
whether it's your family your outside
life business life or whatever do you
think that's today more than ever to be
part of a collaborative environment I
mean back in the day on Wall Street it
seemed like it was a survival of the
fittest I'm trying to elbow any other
guy out there I think everybody always
has to collaborate and for you know
forever listen it's not the be-all and
end-all you could be a tough difficult
person get ahead but you better be
really really really really good at
other things
same thing with being meek versus being
a sales personality you can be you you
don't have to be the sales use
personality but you better be really
really really good if you're going to
rely on the world beating a path to your
door yeah I don't remember being in a
competitive world where I wanted to beat
the person next to me if you wanted to
advance your work hard and I grew up in
a family where hard work was just wasn't
expected it's just the way it was you
never wanted to beat your competition no
I want to be successful used to
teammates versus competition right yeah
but but I mean I'd saw one and brothers
those times I you work with other people
one of the ways incidentally Stephanie
to really get ahead
is to give credit to somebody else when
I say oh I didn't do it Lloyd did that
and he involved me let me tell you I'm
telling everybody it's me as well but
I've now made a friend and you respect
me because I've shared the credit and if
you say no me me me III nobody likes you
and nobody respects it and they think
you are exaggerating everything but to
the extent you give credit to else was
the thought of Allah are they
exaggerating doesn't even come up